ok là c'est enregistré là sans registre
il m'arrive un truc depuis quelques
temps sur youtube c'est que georges
scroll la homepage les tendances même
mes abonnements et rien ne fait envie
alors je sais pas si c'est le titre de
la vidéo sa miniature ou quoi mais à
chaque fois je me retrouve devant je
suis genre - alors au final je clique
quand même dessus par curiosité mais
genre bah je sais pas je la garde de
manière assez neutre
je suis rarement excité parce que je
regarde et je suis même rarement excité
de regarder une vidéo
je trouve ça chiant je crois genre même
la vidéo que vous êtes en train de mater
là maintenant tout de suite genre cette
vidéo là je suis sûr que je la trouverai
chiante georges n'a pas très envie
d'être un mythe gens du coup je me suis
demandé est-ce que c'est que moi qui
recense à et est-ce que c'est lié genre
au fait que ce soit devenu mon job par
exemple et donc j'avais parlé sur
twitter et j'ai été assez surpris des
résultats sur 7600 vote yaggeur quand
même 64% des gens qui ont dit oui genre
oui je ressens pareil que toi coiro et
il ya surtout que 10% qui ont dit non et
dans les réponses parce qu'il ya eu
énormément de réponses
il ya beaucoup de gens qui décrivent ce
même phénomène maintenant que je sais
que je suis pas tout seul à ressentir ça
et que la plupart d'entre vous aussi
qu'est ce qui se passe c'est de trouver
une explication à ça il ya plusieurs
facteurs qui rentrent sûrement en jeu
déjà je pense qu' à trous de contenu
j'étais un sondage auprès de les abonnés
à quelques mois et genre 29% d'entre eux
ont plus de 100 abonnements moi même
j'ai genre 250 abonnement c'est trop
évidemment on pourra parler de pourquoi
on se désabonnent pas dans une autre
vidéo ça c'est aussi très intéressant et
du coup je me retrouve devant une page
avec de plus en plus de contenu et même
ceux conduits là il est de plus en plus
longs genre avant les vidéos et faisait
genre cinq minutes maintenant on fait du
15 minutes easy 20 minutes
voilà le genre c'est devenu un format
qui est ok sur youtube ya pas de
problèmes locaux final je sais que je
clique sur rien ou presque en tout cas
je le fais sans la même envie qu'avant
parce que j'ai l'impression que le fait
qu'ils aient autant de contenu ça fait
perdre à chaque contenu individuel une
sorte de saveur mais surtout ça me
paralyse et c'est là que j'invoque le
pokémon sartre attaque angoisse
sartrienne si vous voyez pas ce que
c'est je vous mets un lien dans la
description en gros c'est le fait d'être
angoissé par sa propre liberté en fait
vu que je dois choisir ce que je regarde
si je regarde un truc qui est pas ouf et
que j'ai perdu 15 20 minutes de ma
soirée et que la vidéo d'à côté était
mieux eh ben je pourrais m'en prendre
qu'à moi même
et donc ça donne pas envie de s'y
risquer quoi c'est pour ça que la télé
c'est super simple georges l'allument
j'ai que si choix explique je fais
résiste servait mois la soupe quoi soupe
n'est pas péjoratif j'aurai la soupe
c'est super important il ya plein de
nutriments dedans ça il y en a qui
disent que ça fait grandir je ne sais
pas j'ai pas essayé
bref la télé c'est sympa ce que tu
choisis pas c'est un peu comme le
syndrome netflix le nombre de fois on
était devant cette page netflix avec
toutes ces séries tous ces films on est
là en fait le temps qu'on choisisse un
truc cool a maté va c'est déjà la fin de
la soirée quoi c'est pas vraiment la fin
de la soirée mais je veux dire t'as plus
autant de temps pour mater ce que tu
voulais tu pouvais mater deux épisodes
permettent et karkwa
mais si ça vous est déjà arrivé ça nous
est tous déjà bref c'est pareil on a
trop de choix
ce surplus de choix moi me donne pas
envie de cliquer bien sociologue qui
s'appelle lucien car piqué qui est
karpik et karpik picard karpik il aimait
bien les jeux les sur picard surgelés il
ya un sociologue qui s'appelle lucien
karpik qui a écrit un bouquin qui
s'appelle l'économie des singularités
singularité donc ce qui est singulier
c'est ce qui est unique
ce qui est original voilà donc il ya
trop d'informations nous on a nos
limites cognitives on peut pas tout
récupérer on peut pas tout capter et ben
il ya ce que lucien crappy qu appelle
l'engloutissement des singularités le
sien karpik par dont certains en gros il
ya tellement truc il ya tellement de
choses que j'arrive pas à distinguer les
trucs c'est exactement ce qui se passe
dans les abonnements youtube
et comme il ya plus de singularité et
donc tout finit par se ressembler karpik
dit qu' il y à une sorte de familiarité
en fait tout devient familier donc on
s'y habitue donc on ne remarque plus et
safran sont parfois les vidéos qui sont
censés être du kif en genre corvée ou
tâche
j'ai parlé à des abonnés qui font des
playlists de à regarder plus tard qui
stresse de pas voir le contenu de qui
ont peur d'être noyé dans le contenu je
les cite comme s'ils avaient une sorte
de pression sociale à mater tout ce qui
sort et j'avoue ça me laisse avec certes
un très gros cube heures je mate leur
contenu mais je ne sais pas si je le
fais parce que je le kiffe sincèrement
ou parce que ben jor j'ai des potes qui
on perd au fait t'as regardé le groupe
une machin etc
qu'est ce que tu en penses blabla et je
crois que la vérité se situe un petit
peu entre les deux mais ouais ya ce truc
un petit peu je pense qu'elle notre
raison qui fait qu'on aboutit à ce
constat et qui cumulait à ce que je
viens de dire
là c'est mal c'est l'uniforme a dit
l'une jeu les rater je les rater
raté l'uniformisation nous les youtuber
on s'inspire beaucoup les uns des autres
et parfois notre contenu commencent à se
ressembler il ya plein d'exemples à dire
mais rien que là vous êtes en train de
voir un mec assis qui parle fait scam
avec un micro apparent un bureau
derrière ou avec un ordi une étagère
avec des trucs dessus des lumières de
couleurs machin qui fait un montage avec
des zooms des zoom zoom dézoom voilà
vous avez forcément vu une vidéo comme
ça soit aujourd'hui soit hier soit au
pire la semaine dernière alors
évidemment parfois on sort de ça un
genre à titre personnel par exemple
quand je vous ai amené au népal la
première fois ou que quand je vous ai
parlé de mon expérience cyborg à new
york et c'était voilà des choses
vraiment différente mais je peux pas
faire ça toutes les semaines et les
oeufs du tube heures non plus d'ailleurs
et puis même ils ont peut-être pas envie
en ligne youtube aime qu'on produit
souvent et donc du coup on aboutit aux
mêmes méthodes aux mêmes solutions
bien sûr je peux en train de dire que
sur youtube tout montrer du fesc âme ce
que je suis en train de dire ce que les
formats s'uniformise en gros c'est à
dire que tout ce qui fonde la voix off
avec des illustrations sympa le font à
peu près la même manière ceux qui font
du réac tous le font à peu près la même
manière ce qu'ils font du blog le font à
peu près la même manière alors oui
évidemment il ya des différents chacun
son style etc
mais au final genre si tu penses
création si tu penses format si tu
penses manière de montessus pense choix
des musiques ce genre de choses c'est
similaire quand même et encore une fois
je dis ça sans jugement de valeur c'est
pas grave genre moi mes coups de fils
par exemple ça ressemble vachement au
podcast de norman là on s'intéresse
juste aux conséquences je parle des
conséquences de ça je dis pas que c'est
de la faute des youtuber j'ai aussi que
voilà youtube est le l'industrie de
youtube est aussi encourage ce genre de
truc en fait malgré elle à voilà trop de
contenu trop d'uniformité je pense que
c'est ça qui casse un peu ma vibe en
tant que viewer sur youtube et qui hélas
se coller sur mon fils d attendre qu il
ya une sorte de magie qui se passe quoi
qui arrive évidemment qui arrive de
temps en temps alors autre chose si on
prend chaque vidéo youtube manière
individuelle donc si on les sort de cet
endroit massive dans laquelle elles sont
distribuées
franchement est ce truc enfin c'est
magnifique quoi genre c'est le contenu
qui est produit notamment en france et
ouvre et j'avoue que je suis sincèrement
sincèrement très fier de faire partie de
cette communauté quoi c'est
mais c'est juste a bien mis en avant
quoi c'est juste mal distribuée c'est
c'est tout au même endroit c'est sait si
le sujet vous intéresse je vous en parle
et hop les azur un festival à nice avec
d'autres créateurs il y aura notamment
un créatif et me code avec qui on va en
parler je ferai un live à ce moment là
sous - instagram
je ne sais pas du tout c'est qu'on le
lève voilà les vidéos youtube sont elles
devenues chiante je crois que ce sera 15
heures 30 le samedi 9 février
voilà je ferai un live sur instagram à
ce moment là si vous pouvez pas venir
sinon venez c'est mieux comme ça on
discute comme ça machin il ya plein de
gens je pense qu'ils sont pas d'accord
avec plein d'autres trucs
voilà on discute et cool voilà j'en
reparlerai sûrement une autre fois sur
ma chaîne suite à vos retours voilà ce
que vous en pensez si vous si ces hauts
faits ce feeling là voilà c'est pas très
grave un footing il vient il parla en ce
moment je les moins il ya une deux
semaines je l'avais grave c'est plein de
choses
j'envoie du love et de la piste ciao et
nouvelle vidéo qui sort jeudi